[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in joe thomas the uh future
hall of famer nfl network analyst former
browns offensive tackle all pro kind
enough to join us joe let's go back to
when baker mayfield and his agent put
out that letter that love letter to
cleveland that uh
it's time for me to leave basically what
did you what did you make of that move
by baker mayfield
well the first thing that i saw it
seemed like he wanted to express
gratitude to the fans because even
in the situation that we're sitting in
right now where baker mayfield is about
to be traded to another team there's a
lot of defenders of baker there's a lot
of fans of baker for what he did for
this franchise i mean my last two years
in cleveland we won one game the next
year we draft baker mayfield and he's
been part of this turnaround including
winning a playoff game against their
hated rival the pittsburgh steelers so
certainly uh there's a lot of love still
in cleveland from a big
section of the fan base for baker so i
think he wanted to express gratitude but
there was also a little hidden meaning
in there i think he was trying to make
sure he could be a little bit passive
aggressive with the team um trying to
make them make a decision so that he
could either have them fall back in love
with him and really open their arms up
and wrap themselves around baker or kind
of start the process of getting him
traded to somewhere he wanted to go and
it turns out that he wanted to go to the
indianapolis colts
well i just wonder if that strategy
by being so vocal or pushing the
envelope a little bit here that the
browns weren't going to get desean
watson at least that was the report and
then they made an offer that he he
couldn't refuse even if he didn't want
to play
in cleveland or in that weather he
wanted to play in a dome it felt like
he'd exacerbated this that maybe he
talked himself out of town and cleveland
had no choice but to go all in on
deshaun watson what do you make of that
strategy
i think that will be when it's all said
and done
the highlight of the baker mayfield era
in cleveland where he was just a little
bit too boisterous just a little bit too
cocky just talked a little bit too much
and that ended up being the reason why
the browns moved on from him because
let's be honest he hasn't played bad
enough where you have to dump him it was
the combination of his prickliness the
comments that he's made throughout his
career throwing teammates under the bus
the coaching staff the trainers the
media getting in little fights with the
media all the time
it was all those things and kind of
showing a propensity to being emotional
and sensitive and not being able to
handle the criticism all the times not
only in the media in social media but
also i think inside those meeting rooms
in cleveland and i think when you have a
front office made up of andrew barry
paul d podesta and then a head coach
with kevin stefanski who are extremely
unemotional extremely calculated and
robotic and by the book and analytical
like it's just not a great fit when you
have that type of a personality that's
trying to fit into a much more
structured and unemotional calculated
decision-making box
do you like this move getting to sean
watson
from a football standpoint it's a
no-brainer i mean deshawn watson is a
bona fide tier one franchise quarterback
um you could argue maybe that like an
aaron rodgers if he would have been
available would be a better quarterback
tomorrow but there's no argument as far
as long-term answer at quarterback that
deshawn watson has been the best one
available uh in the nfl in quite some
time because not only his performance
but his continued upside we haven't seen
him i think reach his ceiling as a
quarterback and he's a young player so i
think he fits with what today's nfl
version of a quarterback looks like as
far as a guy who can throw the football
a mile he can be accurate he can
also get outside the pocket and beat you
with his legs whether that means running
outside the pocket and throwing or
running outside the pocket and making
plays down the field running the
football um
i think i'm withholding my final
judgment a little bit on everything that
i'm seeing because there's obviously
those 22 sexual assault allegations that
are still out there the sexual
misconduct allegations um and there's
still a lot that we who have not been
involved in the investigation
are i think going to find out about down
down the line and i think it's important
for us as fans maybe to not pass
judgment right away even though that's
what we want to do especially in sports
media right what are we supposed to do
we always got to take a stand
but i think in this case it's important
to maybe be a little bit more measured
and allow some more of the information
to come out before we maybe make a
judgment call on the totality of this
decision by the browns
i said this i've been saying it um
why not reach out to this attorney
representing these women if you're if
you're the browns
why i mean don't tell me you did your
background check and your due diligence
when that's where i start
and my thought is the browns maybe they
don't want to know like maybe this
you're already in i mean
he's there he's your guy so
there's not much you can do no take
backs here but i i would have reached
out to the attorney just to say
we're thinking of trading for him
you know what can you tell us and nobody
reached out to this attorney
representing these women i find that
mind-boggling
yeah i think what the browns had said
about it is that they were trying to
keep the pursuit of watson as quiet as
possible and that they knew if they
reached out to the plaintiff's attorney
that the plaintiff was going to try to
use that as some type of a leverage
situation against deshaun in the civil
litigation and the the plaintiff
attorney he's kind of got a a
history of flair and trying to be
dramatic and get his name out in the
media and so maybe they didn't want that
circus and they also felt this is not
something that they said the second part
the first part is what they said they
said hey they wanted to keep it quiet
the second part is just my own analysis
of the situation is hey he's a plaintiff
attorney for a reason like what do you
think he's going to tell you you think
he's going to say yeah desean's innocent
like he's going to try to paint as
terrible of a picture as possible
because his job is to try to maximize
the leverage that he can get money for
those women that he's representing now
with that being said if it was me it
doesn't hurt to just ask the question
right what's the downside of hearing the
worst case scenario from the plaintiff's
attorney which obviously that's what
you're going to get you're going to get
a tremendous amount of bias because
that's his job
yeah and the browns are going to be
paying this civil lawsuit because of all
that guaranteed money and the raise they
gave to sean watson so
indirectly they're going to be paying
for whatever settlement there's going to
be um i was curious your thoughts on
matt ryan going to the colts
uh i love the move
and but also when teams say hey we're
just kind of talking to sean watson hold
on here we still love you and then i
love that matt ryan said no it doesn't
work that way guys i've given you my
career here i was an mvp here we went to
a super bowl here you want desean watson
great if you don't get him i want
someplace else so the colts end up with
matt ryan your thoughts i think it's a
great decision for the colts right
they're a team that's built to win now a
little bit kind of like the browns are
right they've got a good defense they've
got a very good offensive line they've
got one of the best running games in the
nfl they can throw the football if the
quarterback's making the right decisions
which at times carson wentz was pretty
good and they won when that happened and
so i think if you bring in a veteran
quarterback who maybe is not the player
he was five years ago but he can still
make the right decisions he's not going
to put his team in a bad situation they
feel that they've got a really good
running game they've got a good enough
team built around that quarterback
position that as long as matt's matt
ryan doesn't make the type of mistakes
in critical moments that carson wentz
did that's going to be a big upgrade and
i also still think matt ryan can still
throw the football he's not going to get
outside the pocket which limits them a
little bit what they can do offensively
but matt ryan is still a really good
quarterback in the nfl and i think he's
a great placeholder potentially for them
drafting somebody this year or maybe
next year when there's possibly a few
more quarterbacks available in the draft
this uh transfer portal with the nfl
there's not many seats left in the game
of musical chairs so where does baker
mayfield end up
well it's getting tougher baker mayfield
and i think listening to the people in
cleveland i still got a lot of friends
there got a house there um listening to
sports radio there's a lot of people
that are kind of surprised by the trade
value but it reminds me of like somebody
asked hey how much is your house worth
well it's whatever somebody else is
willing to pay for it and right now with
baker mayfield i think himself maybe his
representation and even a lot of people
that were browns fans thought that he
would command maybe a second or third
round pick and he was a guy that teams
would be excited to build their
franchise around
but that just hasn't been the case and i
think it's a combination of up and down
performance a little bit of a low
ceiling because he's not a big strong
fast guy with a big arm that they feel
like maybe they can develop him and a
guy that's been inconsistent and so when
you have a low ceiling you've got a
history of being prickly maybe a little
bit with a lot of people in the
organization and outside the
organization um and you've been
inconsistent and you've got you know a
bigger salary for maybe a guy that's
going to have to come in and compete
there's not a lot of seats that
are going to be available to you so i
think the two that really uh possibly
could be
on the table for baker mayfield would be
a seattle where he could go in and maybe
compete with drew locke for that
starting spot maybe detroit i don't know
what they think about jared goff but
that type of a mentality might play
pretty well with dan campbell you know
he's tight he's a little bit of an
emotional guy so maybe he likes that in
his locker room with which baker
mayfield could bring and then maybe
carolina but carolina really hasn't
shown any interest at this point
but they're starting to run out of
options as well
always great to talk to you joe thanks
for joining us
thanks for having me dan that's joe
thomas nfl network analyst and former
all pro with the cleveland browns